this morning on the dish a taste of the
caribbean trinidad and tobago lied just
off the coast of south america and their
cuisine has seen an incredible mix of
influences from indigenous peoples from
europeans and from africans brought
there as enslaved people island native
debra sardina has added her own
influence training and cooking all over
the world before returning home to carry
on a three-generation family tradition
as a chef and restaurateur
a little bit of extra virgin olive oil
and the curry vinaigrette so bon appetit
people when diners pull up their seats
to food lingo by chef debbie they're so
soft it just goes down melatonin it's an
intimate experience so delicious
catered to their specific taste and
every single time the food was awesome
i wanted a space that people could feel
very comfortable it's all the work of
chef deborah sardina any way that we can
get our trinbego food on the map that's
what we're about she highlights the
diverse food of the region with her very
own supper club i've decided to have
outside of catering an intimate dining
experience where we have our chef's
table we do that caribbean but with a
little bit of a modern twist for our
meal a very little taste of what
trinidad and tobago has stopped this is
a little
no this really isn't
[Laughter]
an introduction that came with a bit of
an education so sauce is a very
traditional
breakfast or liming food
limey
describe liming for us liming is you
know when you are with a group of your
favorite friends just in that space in
that moment great beverage great food
and you're just enjoying whatever is
happening around you so a little bit
more than just hanging a little bit less
than partying could be it depends
because sometimes that line can get it
could build it could start off very very
very cool and it could build
like her menu chef sardina's career has
followed a similar trajectory a
crisscross cultural tour of worldwide
cuisine this is paired with a dalperi
roti which is a flat bread that's
stuffed with split
peas and we have some curry shrimp with
that it's hard to talk food in trinidad
without the back story of the dishes
themselves what is this this is a blood
pudding or blood sausage okay this is
another breakfast item it's with a
little bit of our french influence or
the boudin as they would call it and
then a little bit of asian so we have
our chatsu ribs and uh we call it
singapore noodles which has a light
curry in it and then we have a tabouli
salad with a little bit of garlic lemon
chicken skewers okay
i'll have a little taste of it go right
ahead she created this space after
restaurant restrictions were lifted
during the pandemic i know
what it was like in the states but this
is an island nation of less than 1.5
million
for your industry how how bad was it was
i think like i mean we saw it worldwide
and we fall and the hospitality got hit
really really hard and so in reality you
had to make some tough decisions
one of them to close down her restaurant
54 saddle it was just getting into that
rhythm but
you know i think part of the process of
life is um understanding that if it's
one thing that will always happen to us
is change and how you deal with the
change will determine
where you go like who would think that
being a pandemic i would be sitting here
speaking to you who would think
right so there we go
this is really her second act in life
what was your first first chapter was
working in new york city i went to new
york city technical college i worked the
gamut of different hotels and
restaurants and always wanted to come
back home but not before applying to
study with renowned french chef
madeleine kamen she got her acceptance
just before giving birth to her daughter
erin and then i decided my daughter was
growing up and i realized that i needed
to spend some quality time with her you
know you have those deep desires and
that kind of push you to the next level
eventually she returned to trinidad to
become the first woman executive chef at
the trinidad hilton hotel and conference
center the first of any hilton in the
americas i was like 16 nowadays
what was that like for you to break
through that glass ceiling um
i think at the end of the day you know
there's some
basic fruits that never change but my
daughter and i have a little bit of a
joke where we would say you know you put
on your big girl panties and you just
make it happen so you at the end of the
day you may have to work twice as hard
but you know that through determination
you're gonna you're gonna make it happen
i caught you calling her mom in the
kitchen
her daughter who trained at the culinary
institute of america is now her sous
chef yes she is
a chef to me um but sometimes you know
she flips i'm like mom she's like
she's carrying on a family tradition
established by her grandparents who've
owned and operated blue crab restaurant
on tobago for nearly 40 years as a young
young girl i'd be in both kitchens all
the time
watching them cook prepare food and they
would rook me in to like do little
things whether it's peel garlic or so i
found myself actually like fascinated in
food as well it didn't go unnoticed by
her mother she always had a great sense
of taste on the palate not only am i
extremely proud of her but i would say
that she is a chef you have someone to
pass it on to that's the whole idea her
big idea was to take this food global
she's cooked all over europe a clientele
that's hired her to bring them a taste
of the caribbean are there
misconceptions about the food here
or the caribbean in general i think we
have showcased and in many different
levels that um
caribbean cuisine
can be on any world stage can stand on
any world stage so what are we making
pillow
what that is is basically stew chicken
and to that we have rice pigeon peas
carrots and pumpkin it's all for the
benefit of her island homeland oh love
it
so delicious
cheers i think yeah that's true you did
a really good job madame debbie
[Laughter]
what's up debbie here's to you thank you
and here's to trinidad
oh that's perfect going down
oh yeah well you know what no wine but i
have a rum drink with lime for the
limelight i love sliming ladies ladies
cheers cheers
and in case i didn't make the point
chef debbie was the first woman
executive chef
for hilton property anywhere in north
america central america
or south america so she was huge